o Olá pessoal eu sou Miguel Thomson e a
gente vai conversar um pouquinho hoje
sobre novas linguagens para uma sala de
aula virtual e embora a gente vai falar
um pouco muito de vitalidade a gente tem
que falar um pouco da realidade do mundo
analógico que é de fato o mundo onde
está inserido na e antes de falar uma
preocupação que eu tenho uma enorme
preocupação que eu tenho e é com relação
essa influência que se tem da tecnologia
né de imaginar que é a tecnologia que
vai resolver a vários problemas e eu
tenho uma grande preocupação em discutir
linguagens que de fato são os meios que
fazem a comunicação entre a gente e as
outras pessoas né como é que a gente faz
a transposição do conhecimento do
conhecimento complexo para quem tá
bom e é no mundo que tá sofrendo uma
enorme transformação né então a gente
disse que a gente tá vendo agora o mundo
vuca né que é uma crônica em inglês que
o exército norte-americano criou nos
anos 90 para explicar complexidade das
Guerras e o que que é vou cá né O que
significa volation né assaltante infarto
na a complexo em umbigo esse mundo vuca
que a gente está dizendo é um mundo que
a gente entra para explicar a aula a
sala de aula né então a volatilidade do
mundo a gente tá percebendo agora com um
fenômeno da pandemia como mudou muito
rápido de um dia para o outro né Um dia
a gente tava em casa o outro dia um dia
a gente tava andando pelo mundo nosso
dia a gente estava preso em casa na e a
sua volatilidade
e tem percebido cada vez mais no
fenômenos nos fenômenos que vão
ocorrendo no ano nos anos 2000 por
exemplo nós tivéramos os ataques lá em
onze de setembro onde ocorreu uma
mudança radical do mundo né nós tivemos
os movimentos a quebra Econômica de 2008
as Primaveras árabes nós tivermos os
fenômenos que o Remo no Brasil em 2013
mas que tivermos uma mudança de um
presidente da república e só pra gente
falar de Brasil né então a volatilidade
é isso que a obal não é o sociólogo diz
que é uma modernidade líquida nós
estamos vivendo em tempos tão fugios
então transformadores e tão rapidamente
transformados que eles lembram
substâncias líquidas né um mundo incerto
não é o mundo
as coisas se você pegar as previsões de
uma economia está no começo do ano em
comprar agora são totalmente diferentes
há muita incerteza né então para quem
trabalha com a com escola por exemplo
para quem trabalha com que a escola
precisa de uma certa a uma certa
Constância essa incerteza é um horror
mas 1 a 9 um novo normal que a gente tem
falado serão as incertezas né a
complexidade do mundo mundo cada vez
mais de interdependências nada mais pode
ser definido com uma simples orientação
com uma simples diretrizes essas
interdependências da complexidade exigem
com que a gente para fazer qualquer tipo
de análise a gente a traga muitos
elementos E é isso que a gente tem que
trabalhar na nossa sala de aula cada vez
mais
a estrutura extremamente rígida que a
gente aprendeu não existe mais os nossos
alunos eles têm que aprender cada vez
mais a trabalhar com conexões com
diferentes informações EA ambiguidade é
um mundo extremamente umbigo a por
exemplo ou todas as vou todas o boa
parte das faculdades do Brasil Então
comissionado tem que fazer um terceiro
banheiro por exemplo nar um banheiro
trans na então o própria as próprias
definições de gênero a que tem no
Facebook lá quando a pessoa vai marcar
passam de 50 Então as ambiguidades vem
surgindo constantemente isso exige das
pessoas que elas sejam cada vez mais
analistas cada vez mais reflexivas e
cada vez mais negociadoras de sentido os
professores nesse campo então cada vez
mais
Oi e a gente tá vivendo por Excelência
um professor ficar sofrendo uma
transformação radical de alguém
trabalhava presencialmente ele tá
fazendo umas transformações online né e
trazendo novas possibilidades de conexão
com seus estudantes Então nesse mundo
virtual é um que a gente sendo obrigado
a viver trabalhar com as possibilidades
de fazer com que os alunos atuem
ativamente lá da casa deles é
fundamental e e nós professores cada vez
mais vão ser a aos agentes de
transformação né curadores trazendo
informações de várias Fontes não são
mais do livro que dessa estrutura rígida
do livro novo que ele é importante mas
ele não é o grande resolvedora dos
problemas então nós seremos curadores
trás
um conjunto de outras informações né e a
curadoria também é feita pelos
estudantes Então esse mundo
enciclopedismo do livro esse mundo
Iluminista onde nós não somos já começa
a sofrer uma grave crise então a o
Iluminismo que a foi um movimento
cultural do século 18 que organizou o
conhecimento em disciplinas cada vez
mais tá sendo por sua prova no
positivismo foi um outro movimento que
fez com que acreditássemos na
objetividade do conhecimento é posto
então um risco ou um em discussão e nós
professores do mundo no mundo geral cada
vez mais temos que trabalhar com a
relatividade do conhecimento e mais uma
contextualização do conhecimento o
conhecimento necessário para de
em situações mas ele não serve para
outras situações esse conhecimento que a
gente produz nós vamos ter
constantemente fazer transposições não
só de uma maneira que o estudante
entenda o conhecimento mais um tipo de
conhecimento que na gente vai ter que
transportar para novas possibilidades eh
linguísticas para novos canais Então
você tá trabalhando vão conhecimento
onde você traz a do online né e no
online você vai trabalhar com vídeos
você vai trabalhar com games você vai
trabalhar com fotografia você vai
trabalhar com redes sociais então nós
professores cada vez mais traseiros um
conhecimento relativo visamos o
conhecimento e mais julgamos para os
jovens gerar conhecimento esses modelos
ativos que a gente tem falado
constantemente um dos aspectos é aqui
não só o aluno busca conhecimento
e gera conhecimento Então essa sociedade
onde a gente começa virtualizar nessa
cultura digital cada vez mais uns jovens
produzem conhecimento e nós também
produzimos conhecimento e nós
estimulamos uma produção coletiva do
conhecimento nós professores passamos a
fazer parte de um projeto coletivo
Lógico que nós temos determinados
conhecimentos mas determinados elementos
dos jovens determinados conhecimentos
jovens também fazem parte do processo
então mais do que professores nós
passamos a ser designer né junto com os
nossos alunos que são o quê que é um
designer é alguém que olha o contexto
identifique elementos E propõe soluções
para resolução daquele problema
específico então Professor passa a ser
também um designer também alguém que
propõe Soluções
o junto conhecer os estudantes e mais
nós professores passamos a ser
contadores de história ao mesmo tempo
que você entende uma situação-problema
você constrói uma narrativa para propor
soluções basicamente cada vez mais as
escolas e os currículos tem falado nesse
modelo de resolução de problemas
resolução de problemas temas né a
storytelling Pitch elevator são
conceitos relacionados a contação de
história que a gente não estava
acostumado então o professor passa se
alguém que lê o seu contexto propõe a
sua propõe a caminhos ou conto uma
história e os alunos junto com você
Professor vão propondo soluções
criativas então nós passamos a ser
contadores de histórias e labor
e cases para que os alunos movimento em
aquele conhecimento que no passado era
estático e há contemporaneamente passa a
ser um elemento para resolução de
problemas resolução de problemas que
comumente podem ser elementos lúdicos
como a gente tem falado magnificação o
que que é um game hoje é uma grande
comunicação de Stories com múltiplas
possibilidades de resolução e de
caminhos então Além disso além dessa
toda essa estrutura de contação de
história como uma narrativa é necessário
trazer outros aspectos do conhecimento
como as emoções como a intuição que qual
que é a Escola tradicional a escola
positivista Iluminista achava que era
possível simplesmente eliminar o com
eliminar os aspectos da emoção e trazer
só razão e conhecimento então a emoção é
outro elemento fundante
é cedo cativo além do que é fundamental
que a gente trabalha em dilemas a a
escola tradicional evita os dilemas Ela
traz só a conceitos listas de conteúdo e
ele Minas a parte onde as pessoas
necessitam discutir a fim de buscar
soluções coletivas então trabalhar de
maneira dialética é fundamental quer
dizer tese antítese e síntese a escola
tradicional eliminou os dilemas eliminou
as extensões uma boa escola tem que
trabalhar constantemente tensões porque
o mundo vuca é um mundo de tensões é um
monge onde é onde emergem muitas ideias
diferentes constantemente e a gente vai
precisar negociar sentidos nessas parto
o professor tem que ser cada vez mais
uma pessoa culta cada vez mais uma
pessoa muito bem informada a tinta né
tem que ficar um mês
e para com as questões burocráticas
evidente que é necessário nosso certo
burocracia mas por ser tem que ser cada
vez mais um intelectual Como dizia o
Antonio granchi e esse intelectual ele
não vai um pouco investimento ele vai
movimentar o conhecimento entre os
jovens para que eles possam produzir
conhecimento e para que eles possam se
movimentar dentro desses meios online
então produziram podcast né produzir a
um tipo de conheço de conhecimento
baseado em redes sociais representam uma
brincadeira fazer o o Facebook do Darwin
né construir instagrams né novas
possibilidades do Tik Tok então um o
jovem passa a ser um produtor de
conhecimento e o professor intelectual
ele passa a ser um instigador deste
conhecimento porque lado esse professor
eu tenho que trazer o jovem também para
o mundo real para ele não cair no mundo
nas físico do online porque é
fundamental que a gente entenda que nós
somos seres humanos que muitas vezes é
preciso disco desconectar para se
conectar e isso é fundamental de se
conectar para se conectar Porque todo o
conhecimento tá a serviço do ser humano
a serviço de um projeto humano então a a
nova aula Ela traz elementos do online
traz o elemento do híbrido Mas ela tá a
serviço do ser humano é a coisa mais
importante que a gente pode ter todo
esse Cadinho que a gente tá trazendo
analógico e online né serve para que a
gente Produza seres humanos melhor então
é um um modelo outro homem né quer dizer
que tem um sentido de online offline né
que faz
em constante e que ao final de um
processo educativo que no final nunca
tem um final nós estamos formando seres
humanos melhor então é isso que eu
proponho como uma nova sala de aula
virtual uma mudança de linguagens novas
possibilidades de linguagens novas
linguagens a linguagem antigas no cinema
teatro televisão e outras linguagens
para que a gente faça seres humanos
melhor então é isso Obrigado tchau
pessoal tchau